hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round six its hero Alex ANCA
vs onigiri and it's it's it's a quite a
game quite a theoretical struggle and
well quite quite the grind so I'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it
here's a nice photo before we check out
the game there you have it
nothing out of the ordinary happening
there so let's just enjoy that for a
second and let's dive straight into it
so Geary oh sorry Alex and cope with the
white pieces opens with E 4 and a Giri
goes for a 5 we have 90 f3 Knight to c6
sorry about that
and Bishop to c4 challenging Geary to an
Italian game and my knowledge gear is
gear is one of the the best players of
the Italian game in the world well
regarding opening theory at least Bishop
to c5 and now Giri goes for the Evans
gambit yeah no he doesn't he he goes for
castles he goes into the main line of
the joke Oh piano
we have Knight to f6 and now b3 we have
these 6 and c3 now and the white is the
most likely going for the standard plan
rook e1 that is coming here Knight of
three nights to e3 and so on so castles
bye-bye Geary with rook to e1 and now a
5 now we already had this position many
times on the board nice the g4 with the
idea of going here doesn't run into any
sort of a perpetual because the rook the
rook the e2 is actually fine for white
and then you can kick away the night
with h3 and so on so a 5 by Giri now and
mount Knight B to d2 preparing night if
once the e3 we have Bishop to e6 and the
now Bishop to b5 avoiding the trade of
light square bishop and this is a
position we reach many times in our
videos as it's quite popular so most
often here you will see some like Queen
BH 2 a7 piling got down on the f2 pawn
but here we have Bishop to e7 by giri
and it is a new move in the position
never been attempted before Bishop to b6
was tried Bishop to e7 is a new move so
it is as of move 9 already that we have
a completely new game which is quite
quite a big deal for an Italian game and
here we even have
a nice photo of this moment there we
have it Giri also like nipple likes the
circle his prey while thinking about the
position and also he would have a nice
photo of a wild agree shook appearing
there we have it it's hard to decipher
what he's what he's thinking he's either
disgusted or or he's like man I wish I
thought of that that that is a good
Italian game it's very hard to say but
yeah getting back to the game Alex Sink
who just continues with this plan nice
to f1 Rima nuvaring it's the e3 we have
Knight to e7 now preparing to kick away
the bishop with c6 Knight to g3
instead of e3 now you will have access
to the f5 square if needed
c6 pushing the bishop back Bishop to a4
and now Knight to g6 and here h3 taking
away the g4 square from Gary's pieces
and now as it is possible Gary finally
pushes d5 the knight from g6 nicely
covers e5 so you are you are now able to
execute d5 we've eek a person d5 Knight
captures on d5 and now Bishop back to c2
we have Queen to c7 by giri and d4 now
striking in the center eek actress and
e4 Knight dr. sandy for and now rook 88
and here Bishop to g5 continuing
development and now comes Knight d2 F
for an excellent square for the knight
and already you have some ideas of
Bishop to d5 going after the g2 pawn as
it's so conveniently placed here so
Queen to d2 now with threats of well the
knight could could become a problem here
or if you just capture here then the
knight has to go back but Gary still
continues Bishop to d5 puts pressure on
the g2 pawn here and now first Alex
saying coat raise any eighth row
captures we have rook captures and now
rook to e1
a safer choice might be but just Bishop
captures in g6 and now the knight has to
capture because the night is now under
attack so after captures now you go
Knight to e2 f5 and you you continue the
game so that would be there would be the
safer choice but Alex angle prefers the
rook to you
one and now again a giri giri could go
for route captures here it's definitely
a possibility Queen captures king of
fate and now let's say you have to play
something Bishop characters H characters
now you could trade here Bishop capture
screen captures and you could go into
the same game where where two bishops
are against two knights and black is
definitely to be preferred but Gary
first decides to keep the tension with
rook the e5 kind of kind of forces a
bunch of characters on f4 as now it's it
is attacked twice and basically forces
to trade down into an endgame
so Bishop captures on f4 rook captures
anyone with Czech Queen captures and
Queen captures on f4 Quinta I ate with
Czech by Alex ankle and now Knight back
to f8 and here we have Bishop to b3
other moves are also possible for
example Knight the GTF 5 is very nice
with the idea of just Knight to e7 check
King h8 and followed by Queen captures
and f8 made but Bishop to c5 seems to
seems to take care of that there's no
way to take advantage of this so what
you could do is you might consider
Bishop captures on h7 with check as the
knight is pinned so King captures in the
Queen captures but then black has the
option of capturing and d4c captures
Queen captures so black also grabs upon
and white would have these two pawns
that that are definitely a liability for
example if b3 you can just go Queen a1
checking h2 and you pick up the a to
pawn black this upper pond and should
should have a much better game so those
are the possibilities for white so Alex
and 'can't enjoy either of those two so
Bishop to b3 offers the trade also takes
care of the DA to pawn weakness and now
Bishop captures on d4 by Geary C capture
Sun before and now Queen captures and d4
is impossible because of Knight to f5
which pounds would an attack on the
Queen and after the Queen was just
ninety seven chair King h8 and of course
Queen captures with mate so you cannot
capture on d4 but you can capture here
Bishop captures a captures and now Queen
back to f6 again I would an attack on
the d4 pawn keeping an eye on it but
like I said you cannot capture because
of Knight to f5 so at least give
redoubled
saying corresponds and it is it is a
small plus we have queen Tiye Queen to
e4 by alexengel
and now g6 making some breathing room
for the king and now knife to e 2 as the
d4 pawn might come under attack so
Knights the e6 giri pressures it and now
h4 giri stops the advancement of the H
pawn with age 5 and now III and Queen to
d8 now preparing Queen to b6 the still
keep an eye on the phone here but also
to go after the b3 point and Alexandra
finds a good way to deal with that Queen
e5
now we have Queen to b6 putting pressure
here and here so it doesn't seem like
it's possible to defend both but Alex &
Co finds it with d5 now threatening to
well of course the to capture the night
but if the knight moves you could create
a passport so giri captures we have
Queen captures on d5 and now Queen King
to f8 by Gary getting the the King to
also become active while defending the
b3 pawn Knight to c3 and now Queen back
to c7 with Knight to e4 and here comes
Queen to c1 check here with Knight to e4
alex angkor offers the B to pawn but he
will have a lot of activity and his
pieces will get closer to get his King
so here he goes for it Queen to c1 check
King to g2 and Queen captures and b2 and
now Queen to d7 going for Knight to d6
which will offer some some mates here
and also pressure the b7 pawn so Gary
calmly says I don't I don't think you
have anything just b6 we have Knight to
d6 threatening mate and now Queen back
to f6 by Gary Quinta EA twit check King
g7 and now Queen back to d7 keeping an
eye on the pawn here but now King g8 by
Gary inviting the check again Queen e8
check but now Knights the f8 give it
says this is not a problem I still have
my two pawns and I might be able to do
something about this so Queen back to c6
quite has to play something and now
Queen to d8 just keeping an eye on the
b6 pawn we have nice to see four with a
double attack here and now there is no
longer a way to keep protecting the
point so nice to e6 and now Knight
captures an e6 Queen captures would
a big a big big mistake because after
Queen to d5 check King g1 you have a
four and now you're losing the phone
because if you capture then you lose the
night you would have to defend let's say
Queen before but now it's Queen D 1
check King G - and now you capture the
pawn most likely with a winning endgame
so after Knights the e6 we have night
capture Sun b6 Alex & Co wins back the
pawn and now Knight to d4 a very
dangerous position for Alex & Co now as
for the moment he has control of this
lights for diagonal but if the Queen for
example somehow lands a check on this
diagonal with the knight being here
having access to f3 will be very
dangerous so here Alex & Co has to move
the Queen while keeping an eye on the
night and the only good square for it is
Queen to c5 the the square I like saying
Co plays Quinta b7 is also possible but
Alex tango prefers Queen to c5 so Knight
character son b3 by giri he wins a pawn
queen to b5 and now comes Knight to be 2
again you have to be very careful if you
allow a check along this diagonal then
the knight will again have access to f3
so Queen captures an 85 Alex & Co has to
win back the pawn and now Queen to d3
now with ideas of of Queenie for trick
maybe night of 3 and so on
so here Alex & Co has to figure out a
way how to do this he decides for Queen
- a 1 a little bit more precise it would
have been King 2h - but we're gonna see
why that is so so Queen 2 a1 keeping an
eye on the back rank also not allowing
Queen 2 f1 with check but now comes
Queen e4 check King 2 G 1 and now Knight
f3 check so of course you cannot D
scores are covered by the night you
don't want to go in front of the Queen
on this diagonal so King 2 f1 and now
what do you play
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the Geary's move while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations on
spotting the free pawn and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show its
Knight captures on h4
point being that if you capture then
between the h1 check and you pick up the
Queen on a1 that's the point
so after Knight captures on h4 there is
really not much you can do here again
this is the threat to just check and
pick up the Queen and you also have to
be very careful if you move the Queen
somewhere well weird like let's say a
three then let's say Queen B one check
pic can pick up the night here on b6 so
there really isn't all that much to do
Alexei encode decides for Quinta a8
check he forces a queen trade and now he
just moves back the night and now a
giver he has a three-to-two advantage
but it's on the it's on the same side of
the board with with one night each so
with perfect play it's hard that this
can be more than a draw but these are
humans here of course giri has to try so
King g2 we have night back to e5 and now
f4 by Alex & Co grabbing more space
Knight to g4 and now knights to b6 start
bringing the night into the game King f8
and Gary starts bringing the King into
the game 95 not allowing King is 7 so
kinky 8 9 2 C 3 and now King to e7 Giri
also wants to get his King into the game
94 and now Knight to III with check King
f3 and Knight to c4 and now Knight to g5
we have King to f6 Gary coming closer
with the King Knight e4 check we have
King to f5 and now tonight the F do we
have nice to d2 with check and the King
to e3 now nice the f1 with Czech
threatening to pick up the pawn king of
3 9h to check King g2 and now Knight to
g4 now of course afraid of Knights is
out of the question the King and pawn
and game is winning for black so we have
nice to h3 instead and now f6 taking
away the g5 square from White's night we
have King back to f3 and now King e6 now
Gary will try to wiggle his way with the
King at this way King the e4 of course
not allowing it king to d6 we have nice
the g1 and now King to c5 Gary starts a
circling the the White King King d3 not
allowing it now tonight the h6 with King
back the e39 m5 check forcing the King
to come back then defend the pawn king
f3 and now King to c4
we have Knight to h3 waiting for the
Knights to move and only now we have
night
the default width check King to e3
Knight to f5 wit check repeating in the
movies a few times king of three and
only now King to d4 Knight the f2 and
now Knight to d6 this is an excellent
square for the knight for Geary he wants
them he wants to wait either the King
moves and then I bring my king closer or
the knight moves and then I get to the
e4 square for my knight
so here as you do have to play something
night h3 and now Knight to e4 taking
away one more square from whites night
so Knights the g1 and now King d3
grabbing more space King to g2 and now
Knight to d2 again grabbing this square
these two squares from the White Knight
so King to f2 and King efore now with
Knight to e2 and now Knight to be one
not allowing you Knight to c3 check so
here you have to play something night g1
and now finally h4 by giri now he wants
captures and then captures but Alex & Co
says no way
Knight h3 we have King to f5 and only
now G captures on h4 well the point is
protected here we have King to g4 by
giri and now it seems like Gary
successfully did everything and now he's
gonna pick off the pawns and win the
game but Alex & Co finds the very nice
f5 move so the point is if King captures
if King captures here on f5 then King to
g3 and the game of course continues but
after f5 it's not the greatest of moves
for example if captured the night event
captures here and you lose the game so
it's it's a hard decision Gary knows
that if he he captures with the Queen
King and allows him to g3 then it's it's
raw so Gary wants to play on he plays G
captures on f5 and ok
King the e3 saying that ok
would you play now if you capture if you
capture my knight here then I can just
play King to f4 and I'm gonna pick off
your two pawns and if you try to defend
them Knight c3 captures night here
defending the pawn then I start pushing
my past bond and now you don't have a
way of stopping the passed pawn unless
you go for a 97 check cap first night g8
check King g7 ml King g4 trading a night
for pawn and that's pretty much it or h6
captors and captures
and it's a row by insufficient material
so after King III Alexandro says you you
feel free to have my night but Geary
says Knight to c3 and okay we have
Knights 2f to check by Alex & Co and
here Gary most likely not most likely
but Giri has the capture here let's say
drinking f4 King picks of the pawns and
it's a draw
however Giri didn't go for the pawn gear
instead played King to g3 and this is a
special moment in the game now feel free
to pause the video and try to find a
good move for alex angkor how do you
continue this game well I give you a
couple of seconds so of course for those
of you who found the either of the moves
either Knights the h1 just checking the
King or starting to put the pawn with h5
both of those who work very well
Knight the h1 is a bit more more simple
but this also works so for those of you
who just won't enjoy it show let's show
night h1 the point is after King g4
check night if to check you're gonna go
back and add h1 check we already said it
if you capture then the King gets the
pick up pick up those pawns so this is a
dead draw just repeat moves on the other
hand after King g3 you could go h5 it's
a bit more complicated but after Knight
d5 check King d4 you're gonna go Knights
the f4 h6 King captures on f2 h7 it's
nice to g6 guarding the queening square
but now King d5 with f4 King to a 4 we
have f3 now came to f5 Knights the h8
and how King captors on f6 King G to
king g 7f - you're gonna capture the
night and now f1 Queen and after King to
g7 it's of course a draw because well I
do hope you know that if the pawn is on
on the H square F square C square or the
a square it's a draw and of course if
it's on BD e or G then of course the
position is winning for black so if you
don't know that you should check that
out - very very exciting stuff so those
are the two options after King the g3 h5
and the Knights - h1 check however Alex
and Co play tonight - d3 and here he
just allows the giri to pick up the
point while blocking his kinga way he
misses Knight to d5 check and now the
king has to move away you can't go here
you cannot go here King d4 and now
Knight to f4 again these two squares are
covered by the pawn so you cannot
approach them and you have to play
something the problem is you don't have
time to get back with your King because
there's the the offer of trading Knights
and the problem is you do not have the
option of trading if characters captures
this is just winning for black this pawn
will get picked off and you have two
points to push so Alex & Co had to play
Knight to c5 but not just King captures
on h4 with both of the points surviving
King III we just have Kings to g3 Knight
to b3 you have to go somewhere and now
Knight the e6 preparing to advance the
past pawn Knight B - we have f4 check
King to e2 now Knight g5 securing the f3
Square for the black pawn king f1 just
f3 now we have kinked g1 and here F to
check King to f1 and here Gary just
played f5 and it was in this position
unmoved 98 that kiddo Alex anko resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here f5 is a useful move because if
you move the King then King just goes
here and then of course is just winning
and on the other hand if you don't move
the King you have to move the knight and
after we move the knight then the Black
Knight gets DF 3 square and next move
it's check whatever you do I'd say an IB
- you're just gonna check the white king
he has to move and bring a queen into
the game so really really impressive
game by both of them and really Gary
just it seems like you're retired amount
it's it's sort of an unspoken rule in
the end games that it doesn't really
matter if your position is winning or
not as long as you win it so you have to
try everything you have to tire your
opponent out as much as possible you're
up upon so only you can win this if you
don't blunder and you should always try
to do it so after f5 and Gary did that
and would this win Aguirre actually gets
his first ever win in the candidates
tournament this is not his first
candidates but he in the previous
candidates tournament he had all rows
and here he man he finally manages a win
so really you can see
chess is a cruel game after seven hours
of play Kirilenko finding brilliant
brilliant resources in the game in the
end it all comes down to this silly
moment where you have to decide on this
if you give Alex ink if you just give
Alex think of this position like in 3
a.m. in the morning and you woke him up
and you told him what white to play what
do you do he would say h5 or or he would
say Knight h1 check and you repeat if he
was lazy calculating this because he
just woke up but he would never play
Knight to d3 like he did in the game but
on this one instance he did play it and
it ended now it's it's a win by giving
even grandmasters are humans as you can
see you know things happen in chess and
it will always be that way so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it let's
check out the standings as we didn't
check the standings after round 6 so
here it is yummy pony she with four and
a half out of six incredible performance
I believe I do believe that's a
performance rating of over 3,000 but I
would have to make sure if not maybe
2950 really impressive stuff a whole one
point ahead of Maxine washer allograft
was clear second with three and a half
then with three points we have Fabi
onigiri Ivanka and Alexandre Greece
shook and with two points Carol Alec
Cinco and ding leerin so it's still
early in the tournament but everything
doesn't start running at some points
this will be probably probably the worst
tournament of his life after he became a
super grandmaster but yeah it's still
early to tell will will dink keep having
a betterment and will nipple be having
the tournament of his life
we'll have to see we're still not even
finished with the first half of the
tournament so like I said I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank David
Dunn Randall Ingersoll Danielle babying
Ralph done and Frank combs for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament today is the rest
day so we're continuing tomorrow and if
I will have time today I was squeezing a
nice game from the morphe saga so thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and stay safe